je vois les te tais vous le savez donc
comme ya sophie davant qui est avec lui
aujourd'hui
eh bien on a voulu qu'ils viennent tous
en objet un objet qui les caractérise
et sachez qu'on a le premier objet
puisqu'on va accueillir tout de suite
basse et c'est jean michel lemaire
donc c'est benjamin c'est benjamin
castaldi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà mais vous êtes en quoi on dirait
votre père est bas kelly vous n'êtes pas
si vous grossissez trop on voit quand
vous allez ressentir
[Rires]
merci d'être là et celle évoquée d'où ce
week-end en plus j'ai eu je vous ai dit
1 sur twitter j'ai une histoire de dents
sur la tête de ma mère j'ai subi six
opérations en un week end
non non mais sur l'a9 à mr frêche avait
des dents de partout où j'avais même des
dons ici et on commence à vous alors
vous êtes un kart wii champ car ce que
vous avez perdu beaucoup d'argent qui
n'ont pas du tout parce que tu as roi de
coeur
harry que j'aime j'aime le monde j'aime
les femmes j'aime l'amour j'aime la vie
je vous aime c'est vrai alors vous allez
voter pour le meilleur déguisement et
sachez qu'on va tirer au sort
une personne sur twitter kir a dîné avec
un des chroniqueurs
c'est moi qui offre pour moi c'est
cadeau et ces derniers ont un truc pas
trop cher et on filmera tous à un accord
donc si vous voulez voilà si vous voulez
voter pour benjamin castaldi
vous y allez hashtag objets tp on s'est
pas fait trop chier sur le hashtag
attention on accueille tout de suite
valérie bègue radars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
valérie bndes a lâché surjoue vous avez
passé sur valérie ouellet si vous voulez
dîner avec elle vous n'hésitez pas
comment devant la beauté m'a super bien
et alors elle a fait son émission oui ça
va mais à côté j'ai envie de lui dire
chana tova mais c'est vrai ça n'a même
pas là monsieur ces voix là bas et voilà
donc valérie bonnet vous savez bien
mangé hier soir mais j'essaie de faire
attention
bach matoub on s'attachera bas merci
vous savez qu'elle est allée au
restaurant samedi soir c'est pas vrai
avec des mecs on vous en dira pas
attention à nom alors je sais pas en
quoi il j'ai pas compris en fait c'est
jean michel maire je sais pas en quoi il
est fait pas
[Applaudissements]
ces affaires sont plus à une émission
qui cartonne et du fou qu'il le prenne
pas d'où vous êtes olemps jaune c'est ce
jour merci quoi nuit jour nuit
si vous dînez avec lui fera sa part me
dis attention
nous accueillons maxime quête shopi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et aujourd'hui je vous le dis à 20h10 il
aura le retour de ce coup c'est reparti
alors vous avez de gros scoop ce que
vous étiez à la conférence de rentrée
tf1 il y en a des informations un oui là
là là tf1 thème c'est fx soyez pleins de
choses
d'accord on savait que cali est allé au
restaurant samedi soir oui elle sans moi
voilà rien proposé elle a pris une
tomate mozza à vous auriez été la moins
de faire choc non sans quelques chocs et
vous a manqué ah oui beaucoup
mais pour vous le sortez pas avec vous
vous sortez pas bcp il sort pas non plus
lent il fait des trucs soirée mais lui
moi je vais vous dire la vérité je veux
que cette histoire se fasse cette année
j'en un rôle tellement financement j'en
appelle aux téléspectateurs ça fait deux
ans que vous tournez autour elle en plus
je vous explique elle en train de lui
casser tous ses coups samedi raja il en
fait comme elle elle et lui elle veut
pas le pechoux mais elle veut qu'il paie
une personne chère associative quoi
c'est juste un peu pesait alors ballon
échoue parce que lui il a les oreilles
en bouteille de ketchup votre en plus
votre mère l'adorent
ma mère adore ça c'est bon alors c'est
l'essentiel c'est ma grand mère elle m'a
parlé de sa grand mère il va pas pêcher
votre grand mère
merci ça l'affairé non mais sans rigoler
vous allez avancés avec une fois on va
on va voir ce qu'on peut faire
bon apparemment c'est moi le mot que
tout de suite bernard montiel
[Musique]
là bas mais ça lui la france est beau
bien ce petit truc mais je sais bien
j'ai non mais franchement et bahia
ketchup ketchup et moutarde pour ios
maillot je voulais mon plus que la purée
pour balancer mon mât dictionnaire
non là c'est son problème à lui pas fait
un moment avec le quiz ou qu'il a pris
un peu dérapé c'est vrai tant des
rapaces et c'est le problème du gard à
l'on va cueillir géraldine nommé halo
qua non
[Applaudissements]
je vous rappelle on va accueillir ce
filament de qui sont mis tous en
d'objets après vous allez revenir
revenir normal ça va sinon micro et vous
êtes même classe comme ça alors vous
savez pourquoi je me suis comme ça
pourquoi parce que vous avez une
relation fusionnelle avec votre
téléphone oui vous le touchez vous le
car et c'est là mais votre maîtresse
votre meilleur ami
oui donc j'ai mis mon diadème et voilà
et je me suis dit allez vous faire un
petit merci verra biliaire sida qui a
alors dit moi il ya une meuf derrière
voir des travaux
elle est là comme ça il voulait une
boîte à outils un bon on va de plateau
merci à l'époque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes donc voir à tous et est en
coin alors je suis en bouteille de bière
la marque sur bouteille de whisky
ouais et contrairement à ton sexe à
consommer avec modération bonnet dd pour
chercher mamie qu'il oui alors il
fallait changer ma vie
[Musique]
hahaha
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
des brokers ne voient pas dit bonjour je
relâche parlante
ah oui oui je suis creuse mais hors
creuse ça y est les cas leur île et il
est l'heure d'être avec vous allez vous
mettre à votre pass vous il reste à côté
moi un aigle à côté de moi
logés et vous tirez avec le chroniqueur
la jeune fille bien des manies hashtag
obligé tpm pedigree comment ça dans mon
bébé d'amour ya le balancier qui grâce à
ça c'est grâce à quoi ah ça que je suis
toujours à l'heure ici c'est un truc qui
poussa un saint vous croyez à la sortie
c'est pas pour la plus proche allez on
va accueillir tout de suite
ah ben on en a 1 million dernier fut
sais j'ai compris je sais même pas en
quoi il est c'est gilles verdez reste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
exactement au cube est avec toi la
cuvette des toilettes ouais d'accord si
l'accessoire qui a un coup de coeur ou
coups de gueule aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
ce qui aura un coup de coeur mais un
coup de coeur un coup de gueule et vous
d'accord et vous franchement et vous
jure que cette coiffure va hyper bien
assez vrai ainsi la presse tu va
maintenant je peux la garder toutes les
missions non on n'a pas envie vous votez
pour le déguisement préféré